General ridgeway's overzealous and
increasingly lethal measures in support
of the force quarantine leads to
reprimands and eventually arrest a
court-martial and incarceration
but loyal members of his jtf unit would
break him out
and a ridgeway's influential leadership
this Renegade faction of jtf operatives
comes together forming a formidable and
well-trained militia known as the true
Sons
their aim to establish territory and
dominate the populace it was this course
of action that would have military and
paramilitary operatives from various
deployments around the world abruptly
recalled and discreetly deployed to
quarantine areas within the United
States
by the gate sergeant
looks like you've got a riot Brewing
Lock and Load put it down